all right baby the second year of the
valerian champions tour is already
underway rosters have shuffled the first
transfer season already come and gone
with n.a in particular being mixed up so
how have these teams transformed and
wherever old favorites found new homes
let me tell you
[Music]
all right everyone before we get into
the video i gotta remind you as always
the like button the subscribe button and
to ring the notification bell if you
don't i hear riots bringing back the
aries buff in full force and they're
going to credit you for bringing it back
so
thank you it seems like just yesterday
as we watched ascend stand together and
raise the valerian champions to our
trophy above their heads triumphing over
old favorites like sentinels and gambit
as well as new ones such as crew ascend
prove that they are a force to be
reckoned with nats is on the other side
of this but all he has is that specter
he's already seen one pass cnn finds one
it's all on red car now
and this is what it comes down to one
more man to stand and read god
all the hours you've put in
thousands upon thousands is down to a
1v4 and it's done ascend are your faller
and champions winners
the first of their kind to edge their
names in the history books and they did
it in the shadows surprising so many and
they've worked so hard
but teams are already gearing up to take
their throne and the way they're gearing
up is by shaking up their rosters the
first is maybe the biggest news that hit
the nac in this offseason 100 thieves
nitro has returned home to the world of
cs go this was a badly kept secret
pretty much like everyone knew we were
just waiting for an official
announcement so that happened and nitro
isn't the only valent player to have
made the switch back to cs go both
floppy and automatic return to cs go for
complexity in eg respectively after some
brief stints in the world of competitive
valoren and of course we have the entire
100 thieves saga which actually now
involves another team t1 t1 brought in
steel from 100 thieves remember when
that whole benching thing happened right
before the lcq 100 thieves made the
decision to bench steal their igl and
sub in their analyst boy as their fifth
man at that time they also added seven
to 100 thieves as a sub now both him and
steele have moved on from 100 thieves
and those spots needed to be filled one
hundred thieves have signed baby jay and
eckles joining the team after what was a
tumultuous end to the thieves season and
because i care about you so much and
want to save the embarrassment from your
discord vc friends it's pronounced
eccles
i know it threw me for a loop too just
stay with me now
eckles
good job
good for you 100 thieves are once the
top dogs in north america
they're gonna have to climb their way
back up to the top with a fresh lineup
and we're gonna have to see if they can
pull it off t1 also like snuck in there
while 100 thieves were shifting and took
both steel and seven to their team will
they prove to be assets that 100 thieves
didn't utilize properly will this bite
them in the butt will liz have to buy t1
merch now let's check the bank account
god i hope not now sentinels have done
something a little different
they've made no roster changes sentinels
is staying with their core 5 dapper sick
shazam zombs and tens including raucous
as their coach who you might remember as
the person who came over from phase
after the lcq and who i might remember
as the person who i interviewed and
didn't record the audio for but i
digress said those are on the few teams
that haven't made any roster changes and
that begs the question why especially
when it seems like everyone was watching
and waiting for them to make any sort of
change looking at their history it seems
as of late that the once juggernauts of
the game and masters two reykjavik
champions have begun to falter and
stumble then champions came along and
things just weren't working sentinels
were known for being sharp and
consistent and we just watched them in
shazam's words
fall apart but to some people's surprise
the team itself hasn't fallen apart and
i think it's pretty obvious why
sentinels has a great lineup of skilled
players that works well together did
they perform incredibly well at
champions no that's not a reason to blow
things up when they've already dominated
for most of the time they've been
together cloud9 didn't win it all either
and while vanity is a newer addition to
the roster they haven't made any changes
since he joined the team also like give
credit where credit is due we've seen
some major improvements and showings
from teams all around the world where
you might once have been worried about
any domination this doesn't mean any of
these teams are bad it's just more of a
equilibrium but regarding the whole ni
domination let's go over the roster
changes and make you go oh and message
that one discord server you actually
enjoy being in welcome to liz's roster
roundup definitely recorded in the exact
same day oh my god that's crazy okay and
if i pronounce anything incorrectly
i got no sleep last night sue me
um dicey went to phase clan with face
picking up two members of teal seam
mixwell is bench from g2 lakia who
played a grand total of one time at
champion to the vision strikers moved to
exist
fnatic replaced doma with brave af doman
went to 10 star tsm brought on corey and
rossi cryosells joined except replacing
pure r lg brought on b-dog and mata
after dropping a boy dre and a proto
your boy dre went to eg
crazy raccoons has a new new-ish roster
xander left soar to join v1 team vikings
parted way with their entire roster
zerzia bought the x-10 roster was served
placing pata fan who went to overwatch
ninjas in pajamas has a brazilian
ballarat roster guild brought on called
menta russ and trex and finally andbox
brought on odorus lear and jonah p
i'm sweating
so there you have it a lot of shuffling
that went on but there's a bigger
picture to discuss here i know it might
seem scary to see names that you know
and love like nitro leave and new names
come that you've never even heard of but
trust me on this one
this is good when violence competitive
scene first came into being there was a
sort of perfect storm of a raging
pandemic and a floundering nacs scene or
rather a hibernating nacs scene the
games are similar the skills are
transferable and the competition for
roster spots wasn't as fierce as cs go
so to me it was obvious that there would
be eventual overlap we saw a lot of
former cs go players move to valrant
like steele now on t1 skadoodle a major
winner who was on t1 the dynamic brother
duo of scream and navera on team liquid
and tens a lot of you may know him from
valerian but he did get his start on cs
go but now we have this arrival of
almost two separate ecosystems valorant
are now curating their rosters from
people who are born and bred from the
game and cs go has this sort of return
home of these original heroes and icons
instead of going out and getting the
best cs go player possible teams are now
realizing they need to fill the holes
they have maybe they need an initiator
maybe they need a smokes player maybe
they need a jet player and before you
get your memes ready just know that a
stronger separation from these two games
is better for both
better separation more homegrown talent
all good so what do we want to see this
season as fans of the esport not like
individual fans of teams liz what does
that mean i'll tell you i want to see
competition i want to be kept in my toes
i want to feel the highs of winning and
the lows of losing while watching my
favorite teams compete i want to see
strong contenders for that championship
trophy with no clear leader i want it to
be a good fight to the top
and hopefully these teams with newer and
old lineups can give that to us
so wherever old frida you know the first
transfer scene is coming
did you know it's pronounced eccles i
really did not expect that one i was
like e6 uses
welcome to liz's roster roundup my phone
locked one second
this is a really good drink i highly
recommend it